we should make what should be on your
wife resume
what men value I've heard you all can
chime in is consistency I've been in a
public relationship before and it caused
so many problems because you're worried
about what people say when I was married
my ex-husband didn't even want me to use
certain lotions
um Kevin Samuels would always talk about
like an executive wife what's an
executive marriage all right
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel I have a special
guest today Maggie The Substitute
Teacher Maggie and I have become in Pals
the last day right Maggie that's right
she was an instructor at wife's School
an instructor at wife school I thought
that my cooking was too far gone I could
never come back but Maggie
came and taught me let me double check
oh guys we gotta switch the name of the
stream I forget sometimes you know me
you know me welcome to the stream thank
you thank you so much for having me
Pearl you did a great job yesterday I
did good you did really really good
honestly I was actually surprised reacts
to What should we I'm gonna put react to
Modern women with
Matt I'm gonna put Kevin Samuels because
I was going to do Kevin Samuels okay to
start because we're such we're both such
big fans to him absolutely and his
birthday was yesterday shout out to the
family we will tag you thank you Maggie
there we go I subscribed to you oh thank
you so much I appreciate that so tell
them what you do on your channel and how
I'm gonna scoot this way to get you a
little bit better in the shot oh thank
you okay tell them how your channel
started so I do have a YouTube channel
actually I have three but Maggie The
Substitute Teacher is my cooking channel
shout out to the lead attorney
absolutely
when I heard lead attorney say if you're
over 35 and I'm 47 start a YouTube
channel because you do have life
experience that people need to know I
like to say I've been cooking since 1842
I was just raised that way but um I've
always had a weight problem like I tell
uh Pearl I have whale Tendencies so uh
in my 40s the um weight problem started
to turn into a health problem and I been
able to correct everything by just
changing what I eat drink and snack and
I use those substitutes and that's what
my channel is about tell them how much
weight you've lost so far down 80 pounds
80 pounds
80 pounds it is doing look at it look it
sometimes in life they complain and call
me ugly right and sometimes sometimes
make changes absolutely you can
definitely do it you can learn to cook
you can get the weight off and be
healthy I believe you can do anything in
life I believe you can do almost
anything yeah I was gonna say that's
gonna say except right except you know I
don't know if we can go to like the like
Pluto yeah I don't think I'm signing up
for that yeah but but I I feel like any
skill you can always improve at and get
better at absolutely and it's okay to
start where you start yeah people people
you're gonna start so you got to start
somewhere you gotta start somewhere you
just have to start full stop and you
know it doesn't mean you'll get there
right away sometimes it takes time you
gotta get knocked down a couple times
but my issue with a lot of modern women
is it's like we can't even admit where
we're starting from that's true and how
do you improve if you can't admit
where I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you what
happened to me this week okay okay I'm
gonna tell you this is like a coffee
thought in person this is where I film
them by the way ah I got you so okay so
this week I had a I had a thing on Tick
Tock where I said a lot of you are
shitty wives now now what did I say now
this is by every metric now I'm just
looking at the numbers here one out of
four marriages is a sex list now let's
be honest whose part is that usually on
are there a lot of men that don't want
I'm not saying it doesn't happen right
on top of that on top of that the
majority of us are overweight 80 of
women are overweight in the U.S on top
of that we also are not loyal so so
women file for divorce 70 to 80 percent
of time fifty percent of the time it
ends in divorce and what percent of
modern women can really cook are
addicted to social media now it's not to
say we can't get better that's true but
I just said as a collective are the
wives in my in my age group right are we
as good as the wives 20 30 years ago
hell no hell no and I was like
traditional women don't get offended by
this that is correct because traditional
women agree with me that is correct
they're like yeah you this ain't [__] it
well I wouldn't say it that way Pearl
but I do agree with you that we've got
some work to do and I have to give you
credit for acknowledging that and doing
the work to get better whether it's
learning how to cook or whether it's
getting the weight off and being healthy
we definitely need to improve it since
we're talking about Kevin Samuels that's
really one of the reasons why he started
his channel because he would get the men
ready you know he always used to say
they need their 10 years to be heads
down and eat you know what but then when
they were ready the pool of women that
they had to choose from was subpar so
I'm glad we're here to talk about that
and offer some help I agree I agree all
right let me let me look at that oh I'm
gonna put the chat here okay on my phone
this is one day blessing is gonna we're
gonna figure out how to get it on the
screen
but I don't you know we struggle stream
um
so now also we have such a little a
great little Community here at just
pearly things guys I am trying to get
this email list going
um my goal is to get a thousand emails
right now I'm at 639. okay and
um the reason I want to do that is
because I'd really like to post updates
of where we're gonna be and get and send
you guys Meetup information now I can't
just post meetups on the regular channel
because I don't want to die I got a lot
of people after me you know I mean
um you know I mean I actually want to
repent a different one okay email list
you know I just I I don't need the
haters knowing where I'm at so I need
the fans to sign up so I can notify you
guys where our meetups are gonna be
how do you know the people that are
signing up our fans because don't you
have a London uh anti-purl group I do
have a London hay group but usually they
don't watch my streams now it's not to
say
watch Clips or like they're just not the
type to be on the lies they might sign
up but I know their names so I can just
pull them off the list oh my goodness
okay oh I know I know who you are London
hey group yeah I'll tell you the London
hate group is a variety of women that
have come on the show okay now I'd like
to say there's also a lot of friends a
lot of Pals people that are big fans of
the show so I don't want to sound all
bad
right but with every the good comes the
crazy right so these women have come on
the shows
tell me they say they'll say some
Madness that'll give you some Madness
that one girl said okay she said her
body count
now it was particularly a high guess
what number she said was it two digits
it was it was yep it was pretty heavy in
the two digits uh over
50 less than 50 over 35
close slower uh 32. it was like 27 28.
now mind you I asked this as a joke now
I said all right guys because we're
talking about body count that was a
subject and I was like what's your body
count ha ha and I was like just kidding
you don't have to say it so I let her
know
you don't have to say it so why did she
she's sex positive oh she's proud of
that number she's proud of that number
no dear so so she then threatened to sue
me she then threatened said she didn't
know what she was getting into and so
what I did was my friend that invited
her on the show there was a text from
him to her saying this is a
controversial show here's the channel so
I hear so we had it in we had it in
writing what she was do you know what
I'm like getting into so it I don't
really understand what you didn't know
so if she started a hate group like this
is like this is she was the beginning of
like all the women mad because what will
happen is they come on the show yeah
they say some wild things yeah now had
you you I didn't make you sleep with 30
men I didn't make you do that so why am
I responsible for the words if you want
to be honest about it you know honestly
I think if she had gotten the rah-rah
behind her after saying that she
probably wouldn't have come for you but
it was the backlash it wasn't that she
said it it was the effect of what
happened after she said it because she
probably never had a consequence for it
in her life she never heard the truth
before yeah and instead of giving me a
thank you
thank you for shaming me Pearl now I'm
gonna give you another one Maggie okay
roll number two girl number two
she she
um is an Indian chick okay okay and she
said her body count also on the show
because another guy on the show was like
he was trying to make a point he was
like ladies what's your body count and
everyone was like silent except her she
said it and his point was that no one
was gonna say it and she was like five
and now I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest
okay most guys they're like I've
interviewed a lot of guys now this might
be shocking but they're like under 10
we're okay okay so most guys when they
say when they like would hear five and
be like oh that's not so bad right
according to the men that I've
interviewed on the show right okay now
she was part of the Indian Community and
in the beginning
[__] so now she's shunned
I didn't mean that another one oh my
gosh
came on the show baby mama now she was
talking about how she didn't let the dad
have access to the children oh that's
the worst and I asked if it was abusive
she said no
then and I was like okay well why why do
why don't now and she didn't want to
talk about I didn't really press her on
it okay and I should have but I didn't
know as much about the legal system I
was just kind of okay whatever
a couple months later she's going to
court I guess he found the stream she
wants me to take it down oh you you are
talking to the wrong woman you are
taught you think I'm gonna help you oh
dear I I was like don't play with don't
play with me I'm gonna google your old
last name and find him out and send him
the stream myself don't play with me
don't I didn't do that but if I if I'm
pushed I will uh yeah okay kids lesson
for today the internet is forever and
pearl is not playing games and I'm not
playing games and I know I will not
remove any of the screams because we
read them the rules ahead of time we
tell them it's gonna be used for clicks
we're gonna do this we're gonna do that
here's the waiver sign it you know and
it's like what
so you know that's that is how the hate
group started wow I'm gonna just read a
couple super chats pearly I think you're
the bee's knees
um what's the best way to reach you
about coming on the show I'm a
Libertarian perspective system exploits
both sexes puts them against each other
um
I mean it's to get on the show is a bit
hard as a guy it's easier as a girl than
just being honest
um because we just have so many men
getting on the show I don't know bother
my recruiters is the best way I would
say to do it I I don't personally get
people on the show really
um first time live love this information
so so okay so today you know what I was
thinking we could be fun to do okay I'm
a little scatterbrained sometimes
sometimes all the time yeah all the time
um
we should make what should be on your
wife resume
then we can make this together okay
gonna make one sure all right what
should what do you think should be on
someone's wife resume
uh well since I have a cooking channel
the first thing I would talk about is
meal preparation or cooking experience
meal prep or cooking experience okay
periods okay what else uh I think if
you're getting married you probably want
to have a family so I would talk about
your either babysitting or love for
children or anything that is uh your
experience around
um the little ones okay what about my
bag
should a lot of women want to talk about
their career their bag should we put my
bag on here absolutely not I don't care
about that oh no back okay just double
checking yeah no
okay what else what else
um well since we are talking about the
bag I would talk about uh your ability
to manage money stick within a budget
manage money that's a good one no we
have never come up with that one yeah
it's important I mean if you want um it
depends on the type of marriage that
you're going to have and we talk about
this a lot you need to know the type of
wife that you want to be and you need to
know the type of marriage that you want
to have because there are different
kinds you know sometimes people get
married if it's a political figure and
he just needs someone to look good on
his arm or somebody could get married
for papers if there's any kind of legal
situation but in most traditional
marriages if you have a breadwinner
which is usually the husband but it
could be different if you are going to
be in the role of the wife or the
support system you are not the
breadwinner which means you have to be
able to work within the income that is
allotted for the family ability we're
going to do types of marriages after
this okay this is so interesting okay so
ability to manage money or stick to a
budget what else I would talk about uh
relationships family relationships like
your family of origin I think that's
really important because when you marry
you're not just marrying the person
you're really combining two families
because that's how it's been for you
know hundreds and thousands of years
you're really bringing two families
together
what what would you like what do they
need to know about I would want to know
the status of your family of origin you
know were your parents married what kind
of example did you see growing up of
relationships if your parents are not
together is it amicable
um do you have a small nuclear family do
you come from a big nuclear family all
of that comes into play because that is
what's going to set your expectations
for either what you want or you don't
want wow that's true because I feel like
the way I look at things sometimes it's
from like a big family point of view
yeah so like when people I'm just
thinking of I know not everyone goes on
vacation but that was a big part of my
childhood like every summer boot's been
a month to go on vacation and the
thought of just taking two kids and like
flying somewhere was unheard of to us
yeah absolutely and for me it's the
complete opposite so uh when we were
planning for children my ex-husband now
at the time we both come from families
with two children so it's me and my
brother and it's him and his brother and
so I'm a boy mom times two and so after
I gave him two sons we talked about and
I asked him if he wanted to try for a
third but because we were used to that
family of four he said this is enough so
we stopped but I know you often talk
about having that big family experience
so for me it's kind of foreign every
time I hear you say I have nine siblings
it's like who does that does that but it
matters so what else would you say
should go on the wife like what what
should you think about when looking for
a husband or
yeah I mean this is kind of a
comprehensive like what what are other
things to think about for the women if
we want to look for husbands okay so
well I would switch that we don't look
for husbands we are found by husbands so
we present ourselves as wife ready
um I would say since you mentioned the
bag if you do want to work what is the
plan for that is it going to be part
time is it going to be a work from home
are you going to have to travel commute
is it something you can do you know
maybe once a week or once a month just
to keep your license so if you are going
to work what does that look like and how
does it support the family oh if you are
going to work what does that look like
because you tell well you tell them what
you told me about how you worked and
like also had a more traditional
relationship yeah absolutely so I've
been corporate since College I work in
technology so I work for a software
company and so it's a you know uh
competitive masculine environment and I
admittedly got caught up in that Modern
Woman mindset and what happens literally
I hit the wall and we talked about this
yesterday when you're in your 20s you
really can't see your 40s but now that
I'm in my 40s I can see 60 really really
easy and I don't want to do 20 something
more years of that so you know like a
lot of women I had the two hour commute
I was going for the promotion everybody
two-hour commute wow that must have been
a long day it was an incredibly long day
but when you don't think that there's
anything odd about that you just get in
line with everybody else and March
towards the um March towards that
routine so what ended up happening for
me like a lot of people with the
pandemic think I was able to work from
home and it was kind of like we're going
to try this out for a few weeks and I
ended up loving it I was able to cook
more and eat better get the weight off I
was less stressed I was sleeping better
and I was just a better mom overall and
you know happier in my relationship so
you know long story short uh now I work
remote and I'm never going back to the
office
foreign
[Music]
a week with your family yeah exactly but
you probably weren't even thinking about
that you're just thinking about it's
like what you're supposed to do
absolutely because I mean let's face it
and Corporate America is great I've
worked for some really big companies but
they like to get us when we're young and
kind of extract all that energy and that
you know intellectual capital and you
end up putting all of your best efforts
towards a company who could either
restructure or be absorbed or say thanks
you know you've aged out anything could
happen so just being mindful of that
it's great when you can get it the
promotions the bonuses all of that and I
still work but I do it in a way that
serves me and like I told you yesterday
I am known to tell my you know my boss
my work is what I do it's not who I am
so what else should we present to the
husband will I
for sale since you have had some whale
attacks
um that our fitness Fitness yeah okay
it's huge and we can't deny that you're
in shape yeah and what is your Fitness
routine exactly
Fitness routine yeah I'd love to know
what other people think or what you
think I think these are great I think
some of these I've never even thought of
before
um
like the ability to manage money or
stick to I've always I've never been a
huge spender to be honest I've been
other than Ubers I really like ubering
grocery delivery
cheap here to be honest I use it too I
love it yeah
um let's see the comments say can you
take constructive criticism oh that's a
good one that's a good one feedback how
how do you handle
constructive
criticism and that one kind of goes back
Pearl to what we talked about with your
nuclear family when you grow up with a
strong father you all know well maybe
you all don't know but I am an immigrant
born in Ghana raised in the South so I'm
an Atlanta girl but I am used to getting
direction very bluntly and then maybe
you go cry in the corner but you get
yourself together and you move on it's
not the end of the world and so if you
don't have that and you've been coddled
and you haven't had siblings that you've
had to kind of you know
um compete with in a way you get
feedback as an adult and it can destroy
you and that is not helpful in a
relationship that's the one thing I
think volleyball really helped me with
is like you can just you can take
criticism so easily because you're just
so like if you don't take the criticism
you're riding the bench absolutely I
think sports are great and I told you
this yesterday I think my guy says it
all the time I think all girls should
play a sport because it gets you in that
state of mind where it's like okay I'm
not good enough up in this area I need
to work on it and that is a skill I saw
that with you yesterday with the cooking
we poached the eggs and you did four of
them and if it wasn't right he said I'm
gonna get that right I want to try again
and I could tell that's the athlete in
you so it's a good quality
I'm gonna read the next one okay
um I love this mentoring collaboration
how do you use recruiters
um go through
go through my following
um find on Instagram
there's one named Jordan and there's one
that's like
if you put in recruiting I think it'll
come up
um
would you come on our platform it
reaches about 10 I mean it depends on
you can email me just pearlythings
gmail.com
um
Dave Navas having a woman that won't
bleed you dry and keep your neck up in
debt is important absolutely that's the
one thing like a lot of girls their
lifestyle is so like a lot of my friends
it's it's like I make more money than
them but they live like such an
expensive lifestyle like they all have
fake long nails like which which are
they they add up it's like 200 like
they'll go to nice places it's 200 bucks
every time they go roughly or 150 to 200
because they're Nails in there and then
on top of that like if they get lash
extensions if they get BOTOX if they get
friends your age are getting Botox
um these are more girls that I can just
tell on the show that they've had it the
girl the girls my age don't Botox not
yet but I there's yeah it's a shame
Botox lip fillers like yeah it fake hair
oh don't even think yeah and it's just
like
maintain that because it's like unless
you do really well which what percent of
girls are gonna get the opportunity to
be with a guy that does really really
what some will but it's not the majority
so the majority are gonna have to date
and I don't want to say have to like
it's a bad thing like the majority will
date average man and marry average men
if they get married at all so
how are you gonna afford that with kids
you can't first of all it's fake and
second of all the men don't like that
you know men want you they want to know
what they're going to they want to see
you in every environment you know can
you swim can you you know get in the the
carpool can you you know be active all
of that is an expense and a lot of times
you know women we do that for each other
I shouldn't say we but you know you want
to present yourself well but you want to
do it in a way that's sustainable what
men value I've heard you all can chime
in is consistency and the problem with a
lot of that elaborate put on first of
all they don't like it but it requires
so much maintenance and then you go from
looking like you're going on the runway
to who shot John so you know find a
routine that works for you and make sure
that you know number one your man likes
it because ultimately I don't care how
many compliments I get from women if my
man says I don't like your hair like
that I don't do my hair like that
because ultimately his opinion trumps
you know what everybody else would say
and that's like
that's like that is very much like him
before me which is you know how it
should be but it's not common nowadays
yeah and I understand you know and I
kind of got caught up in that you know
thinking it was a partnership but the
problem is and I told you this yesterday
and especially at my age at 47 it
happened after two kids at 35 40 you
really feel yourself as a woman like
okay you know what I kind of want to
slow it down I want to set it down and I
was one of those in my 20s I thought I
could do everything a man could do
compare that to the men that I know at
my age they are putting it in second
gear they're starting businesses they're
investing they kind of have this like
I'm running out of time I want to go
hard so
I you know how you say
women shouldn't vote because they don't
have to go to war
so for me it's kind of the same thing if
I am not going to carry the same load
until 65. oh I should submit because
he's willing to do what I'm not that
that's so true because
I never that is such a good point
because a lot of times girls will say
well I make more than him now
but or or I out earn him how could I
submit but at the end of the day they're
gonna work longer than us absolutely I
mean if you look at it I know we like to
idolize some women that have it but how
many older women do you know are still
going just as hard in their 50s think
about that right I really that is such a
good point so even the ones that we
admire you know I don't want to drop any
names but you all know the ones that are
really really
um well to do they start stepping back
in their own way but if you look at the
men that are really wealthy you know
they are opening new businesses and you
know acquiring more things and so that
is I feel like the value that having the
older women speak to the younger women
it's like I see myself in you but I also
see you know Maggie at 60 and I'm making
decisions now that it's going to make
that period of time a joyous one oh my
gosh that reminds me of my dad because
he retired he sold his business and he's
just starting a new one exactly it's
like they exactly how many men do you
know that retire from their job I told
you about my dad yesterday and they stay
at home for a few months and they just
like they got Cabin Fever they can't do
it my dad's a retired teacher a PhD he's
a you know retired teacher and he stayed
at home for a little bit and now he's a
real substitute teacher every time they
call him he's back in the classroom
whereas my mom on the other hand she is
ready to just you know slow it down
enjoy the grandkids and grow old
gracefully so that's what's coming
that's such a that's such a good point I
never thought of that what what else
should be on here oh dear so we talked
about money so we talked about did we
talk about
intimacy since you were talking about
body count I think um no but let me put
it on here intimacy right I mean that's
an important part of the marriage it's
how you connect with each other and I
know you talked about body count I think
isn't it Sex and Money the two big
reasons why marriage fails just fail so
I think that's something that you should
address head on and the couple should
agree on what's important to them so
what does that mean well intimacy
specifically means you know your drive
does it match oh do they have equal like
right sex drives right and even if you
don't are you willing to
be you know available to your husband if
we're talking about women if he
is interested more than you are you
really just have to kind of have those
conversations we get the ring we get so
excited we want the big day and then the
honeymoon is over and you're looking at
him and he's looking at you and you're
like oh man what did I get myself into
but you really need to talk about all of
it
[Music]
right so we talked about
money we talked to family we talked
about work
um foreign
I know communication is
um one of those words that's kind of
like what does that mean but I think
communication styles are important for
example I don't know if it was you or I
was telling somebody else I know my
um triggers or difficult conversations
and I will still have them but as a
woman because I'm emotional I can tell
my guy okay this is a little hard for me
I need a moment it could be an hour it
could be 24 hours I will come back and
have this conversation but I want to do
it from a place of being level-headed
and not have an emotional response I do
that too if I'm really mad about
something I my mom always told me to
wait two days yep and she said if you're
still mad after two days you can talk to
them but like if you just wait because
like especially if we're close to our
time of the month or like where we are
in our cycle like there's very many
times where I've been so mad and I woke
up and I was like wow I was overreacting
and I was so glad I didn't like say
anything or or talk to them because it's
like if I if I did then I would have
maybe said something I regret and like
just sometimes like waiting is like the
best thing you can do as a woman because
we're like you know there's a part of
every girl that's a bit crazy and
sometimes you gotta you gotta take care
of that yes and it's okay just admitting
that and knowing that but it's not okay
to just act it out well I feel this way
so I'm gonna do this no I feel this way
I want to do this but I have a brain so
I'm going to wait and I will you know
come back but just give me a moment and
we need to understand how men
communicate because they are very direct
and they give direction and sometimes
it's a little harsh but when you know
you have a good one and he loves you you
just need to be able to take that listen
to what he's saying and not get so
concerned about the tone because they
communicate differently from us so I
think that's important to talk about
what what else are we missing oh dear
let's see
um we talked about money communication
what other things do people have issues
with
um I would talk about like social
including social media
um so your expectations for your friend
group and your presence on the internet
what you're gonna share what you're not
gonna share with us no that's such a
great that's such a great comment
because I've actually like
I I feel like I've been in a public
relationship before and I I actually
would prefer to like not tell people
about that at all until like like I I
feel like if people always ask me about
like who I'm dating and like all this
but it's just like I feel like it's just
no like I just rather nobody know until
I'm married and once I'm married you can
know who he is like yeah but it's just
like because I've I don't know if that's
it would also you know it depends on the
guy too like yes but it's like
I don't know I just I've been in a
public relationship before and it caused
so many problems because you're worried
about what people say Oh yeah and when
people think and it's just I I hated
that it's it's not worth it there is no
benefit it's just basically feeding
people's curiosity but at the end of the
day it doesn't change anything about
your relationship so I would 100 percent
uh recommend that it's private
especially when you have a platform like
this because not everybody wants the
best for you and they'll smile in your
face but then you know look for ways to
undermine and being in a relationship
can be hard enough especially when
you're just starting and you want to
have a good foundation I keep my
relationship private and I think the
happiest people that I know we found out
when they wanted us to know and not a
moment sooner
what would you say
um
for girls because a lot of girls get mad
their boyfriends won't post them do you
think that's a reasonable thing to be
mad about absolutely not I think he
should embrace if he wants to protect
you
see and that's such a that's so much
better of like a mindset than because in
all honesty I I used to get mad about
that like like when I was younger me too
and then it's just like I didn't realize
that he was doing it because of the
problems that like came with it later
yeah and in all honesty like in
hindsight I like realized I was wrong
about that because it's like
I don't know it's just it I saw the
problems that came with it yeah the way
that men look at the world they operate
like the enemy is always at the gate
they are looking ahead at what's going
to happen after and as women we often
think about the moment right we think
about oh it's going to feel so good to
be claimed to be spoken for I want that
you know I went through the same thing
where it was kind of like ah why do we
have to keep this quiet but I held it
together and I'm so happy now especially
having a public platform that you know
nobody needs to know because you can ask
yourself okay are we making we make a
post we are what do they call it
Instagram public or Facebook public and
then what
everybody that you know is going to have
an opinion about it so then you're going
to find yourself explaining for
analyzing every interaction I mean you
see it all the time on I mean I do it
first I do it sometimes you know like on
social media like Will and Jada
they were the perfect couple and now
everyone overanalyzes every little thing
absolutely you know just like the two
ladies that share their body count
whether your body count is high or low I
would recommend keep it very low why
does anybody need to know that moment
that little thrill that you got that I
have 27 people that I've slept with or
five people that I've slept with now
that it's out there in the universe
universe how is that helping you you
know and we're talking about Kevin
Samuels what he always used to ask what
does that past bring the future husband
that you want so there are some things
you just need to take to the Grave
wow
what else on here all right we talked
about social media so we have social
media on here but I would also add like
friend groups oh because where do you
think oh I was gonna ask this earlier as
women
we need to talk about our problems more
than men absolutely would you agree with
that so when something's frustrating us
I feel like sometimes men it's this is a
fight that I feel like I see happen and
it's like a very much like the Sexes
don't understand each other because
women we want to talk about our problems
right and men want to solve them all the
time so we if we go to the men they get
frustrated absolutely because and it
because they're like well you're not
asking me to solve it but at the same
time the men don't understand why don't
you just not talk about it right and
where where do you think women should go
to talk about their problems so a couple
of things you definitely need a group of
other women that want to hear all the
details if you want to share them but
also want you to win so it's really
important to have that group that's
another project that I'm working on we
can talk about later if you want to but
you have to understand the way that men
think and if you are going to talk to
him I would reverse the order so if
you're asking him to make a decision
lead with that so sometimes I'll tell my
guy
I don't know let's say something at work
happened you know I will say you know
should I do this should I travel for
this meeting or should I stay home and
then all the reasons why I think it
might be a good thing or or a bad thing
sometimes as women we give all that
detail and men are looking for how do I
how do I so true yeah exactly I just
could think of a couple times right so
it's exhausting for them you can even
use that in the business world like even
in a meeting like set an agenda the
purpose of this meeting is or what I
want to be able to do after this meeting
is make a go no-go decision try to
operate that way and just understand if
a man doesn't want all of that it's not
that he loves you any less it's just
that it's a burden that he can't do
anything with
um so help him help you so find some
girlfriends if you must to talk about it
but if you are going to talk to your man
lead first and then ask him do you want
the detail he may say no and be okay
with that that's a great advice
what what else on here
um anything else we're missing I don't
know what did they say I did do we put
friend groups on there because I think
oh yeah that's that's so true you know I
there's this girl I follow I want to do
reaction to it okay
um no I didn't well I didn't maybe maybe
that could show you actually but but she
um
I followed this girl her name's like
bunny on Tick Tock and she's a big age
Gap right she's dating guy like 25 years
older okay and I just saw the slow
evolution of her being married and she
moved to LA to like pursue the Social
Media stuff
and then she started hanging out with
some other single moms and then they
started going to all these events and I
just remember like watching in real time
thinking this girl is gonna get divorced
because she's not acting like the wife
no like she's wearing these scandily
clothed outfits and I'm just like she's
she's and she I just saw a video of her
crying on Tick Tock talking about how
she got divorced and I was yeah and I
was thinking the friend group's
important so what are you gonna say
about friend groups right I think it's
important to know who's going to be in
your circle and share that with your
spouse so you know he may ask you to cut
off some male friends or some
girlfriends that aren't really helping
you be your best self
um if you have expectations or you like
to do I don't know girls trips or guys
trips or you know go out all of that has
to be talked about and I would say if
he's not a fan of it you should lay it
down because ultimately he's the one
responsible for you
what else
hmm I'm gonna milk you for all the
information I see because this is super
this is actually super helpful you're
bringing up a lot of stuff I never even
thought about oh well thank you
um you know we we talked about health I
think uh in addition to the food any
Habits Like how much you drink if you
smoke if you do any of that kind of
stuff you know you shouldn't assume that
people are you know just okay with it
hopefully you treat your body well but
if you like to do anything you know
recreationally
um
I would advise highly advise against it
but you know you just want to be on the
same page you don't want someone saying
oh it's natural and someone's saying I
don't want you to put that in your body
when I was married my ex-husband didn't
even want me to use certain lotions when
I was expecting because he didn't want
you know anything too strong on the baby
and I said doesn't make sense to me but
you know what it doesn't have to make
sense to me I'm gonna let it go this is
not the hill I'm trying to die on
how much you drink if you smoke yeah any
of that kind of stuff what else
ah let's see do you listen to Pearl
um
goodness if you feel like this is it
then we can I think this is pretty good
I don't know if anybody else to say
anything if anything else comes to they
said it's about facts not I feel like I
know sometimes when I think when I talk
I say I feel like oh yeah
um let's see willing to compromise
um if single mothers apply must provide
character reference and be transparent
about the relationship status with the
co-parents of the child
what do you do under stressful
situations they said yeah yeah I think
we talked about the stressful situations
uh in that communication section knowing
how you handle that but I do agree I
mean we talked about this yesterday I'm
not necessarily a believer that that big
beautiful blended family is always the
best thing I know it can work but it's
extremely hard so I'm not doing that but
I do agree if you do have children or if
there's any other thing that you're
attached to what is the relationship
with the other parent because even if
they're just you know happily
um
going along things change when when you
get married we talked about that
yesterday and someone may say you know
well I don't want that person around my
kids you just kind of know what you're
walking into so that's why I kind of you
know beware yeah so you talked about
earlier the types of marriages that's
what so you said executive marriage or
political political marriage right and
and for me that's just the type of
marriage you know we had a certain
president and I'm not saying anything
politically but if you have a president
a senator a governor maybe this is
someone that was selected for them to
help soften their masculine image but
they may go their separate marriage
um is it you know a marriage for papers
you know maybe it's like um an
immigration situation that you all agree
this is what we're gonna do uh it could
be a military marriage where you know
you want somebody to be
um you know yours when you come back
home but they're gonna have to live I
don't know 11 12 months alone I think
when we say marriage we have an
um an understanding of what it means to
us but we have to make sure that the
person we're marrying wants that same
type of marriage because if he wants to
just be like is my dinner ready and then
you go your way and I go my way and you
really want somebody to bond with and
laugh with you guys are thinking about
marriage completely differently and none
is better than others but you just got
to make sure that the type of wife or
husband that you want to be matches with
the type of marriage that you want to
have
[Music]
um is there anything so traditional
marriage military marriage papers
marriage political marriage Kevin
Samuels would always talk about like an
executive wife what's an executive
marriage um so the executive wife you
know I see a little bit of that in me so
that is usually uh maybe a second
marriage or when someone's older and
there aren't going to be children
involved right so you are basically
um marrying maybe a one person or a type
of man or a high value man uh that needs
you to be a support system to him uh be
the feminine asset to support his brand
uh make sure you can conduct yourself in
any circumstance we used to hear on
Kevin's show a lot of times Well I can
get together when well no he kind of
needs you to be on all the time because
you never know when someone is going to
call you and say hey we're doing this
thing so the executive marriage is
really
um not the like soccer mom which I love
that there was a time for that but
second time around for me it would be
more of a support system to a high value
man
here too yeah that one I'm not too well
versed in but I know there's different
types of marriages and they're you know
Millennials and other people who get
married and maybe the 50 50 can work the
only thing I would say about that
circling back to what we said 20 years
from now if you're working 40 hours and
he's working 40 hours and maybe you all
choose not to have children and you just
use your disposable income to travel and
all that
I would still say as a woman you're
going to want to slow it down and to a
man the way he looks at it is wait a
minute you're flipping the script on me
you said we were going to ride this out
we're gonna go 40 years hard in the
paint I'm still going you know saddle up
let's go and you're kind of like oh man
6 a.m again do we have to do it and it's
hard to see that far ahead when you're
in your 20s but you know with
communication uh you can make it work if
you don't want to have children you need
to say that don't lead anybody down that
path if that's not what you want yeah
but gosh that is such a great point with
the I never thought about the like later
in life like women aren't going to want
to work as much yeah so even if it's 50
50 now it doesn't mean it'll be 50 50
forever exactly what do you think
um
what do you think about do you think
women should be entitled to money after
marriage entitled no
um like what do you think about child
support
um alimony like what's your what's your
opinion on that stuff so I have to tread
lightly here because I know there are a
lot of people that you know this is
their situation and and I understand
believe me so alimony is just money to
um
make sure that a woman is not destitute
I think it has turned into you know I
hit the lottery so let's talk about
alimony and I am a believer you know in
prenup so this is something that you
have to talk about but if a woman the
way I believe and I'm no attorney but I
believe that if it was a woman that was
a stay-at-home mom she gave up her
career dedicated herself to the family
she's been out of the workforce for 20
years and for whatever reason the
marriage ends
if she's not able to get right back into
it for a period of time
um
I hate alimony because that's kind of
enforced but I understand why it's there
I would hope that you know not all
divorces have to be horrible and if you
have the type of relationship where you
were a good woman you know to this man I
would think he would want to make sure
the mother of his children is not
destitute so I think most men it's just
like when the girls start to get crazy
oh my goodness yeah like I think a lot I
got girls would get a lot well I don't
they probably wouldn't get a lot more
because of the legal structure but I
think like I think of uh my grandparents
have um one side were separated and it
was funny because they're separated but
they just like still acted like they
were married absolutely absolutely I
mean it's doable my ex-husband and I a
lot of the boys teachers didn't even
know that we were divorced we would show
up at the events together parent-teacher
conference I'm putting stuff on his
calendar like it doesn't have to be bad
if you know that okay the marriage isn't
working but you still are you know good
people to each other I just think most
if it's reasonable I think that most men
would want to make sure that you're okay
but that means that okay you know what
maybe I need to go back to school and
get a certificate maybe it's going to
take me 18 months or I'm going to start
working part-time and then get my way
back up like you have to come with
something you can't just sit back and
say take care of me until you know
forever that that's just me I know a lot
of people have strong opinions about
that but I'm a boy mom so I see things
differently